this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at a series that
he's deeply nostalgic for Left for Dead
I'm not sure why but I don't really
remember using the MP5 in Left 4 Dead 2
which is weird because I played lots of
it and I love mp5s most egregiously the
only thing that really matters here
there's no HK slap make sure to
subscribe and let us know what other
games or guns you'd like to see Jonathan
breakdown in the comments section below
right let's take a look at the guns of
the Left 4 Dead franchise
this is tremendously nostalgic for me
this whole this whole thing so this is
uh obviously the famous cult government
as it probably ought to be called but
never really is it's the Colt 1911.
these I've got the akimbo 1911s in front
of me the way that Finleyville Armory
spurious marking obviously is on the
right side of the slide is clearly meant
to evoke Springfield Armory which in its
modern form is nothing to do with the
Armory that made US military weapons
it's a company that makes Firearms but
they do make 1911.
come
pistols which these are and they are
almost 1911 A1 pattern um but we do we
do have um a sort of a round shaped
Hammer instead of a Spur hammer and we
have or on the right hand side anyway an
enlarged competition safety now I think
that's there because they they knew they
were going to Kimbo these these puppies
so they've got the standard 1911 safety
on the left and then they've got this
ambidextrous safety on on the other side
that's all well and good but it doesn't
magically let you detach the magazine or
drop the magazine using your left thumb
you'd have to have the magazine catch
switched over for that and if you're
picking them up in the field as you are
in this game that's not possible these
absolutely fine the only issue with them
really for me is the 15 round capacity
suspiciously identical to the Beretta 92
capacity which immediately makes me
wonder whether these were actually meant
to be Beretta's originally and they
changed the model but not the specs
foreign
next up the uzi apart from looking from
this angle a little bit squished a
little bit short this is the full size
IMI as was Uzi nine millimeter sub
machine gun don't need me to tell you
about the user it's pretty pretty famous
and I remember using this a heck of a
lot in left for dead and I don't think I
really paid much attention to things
like its rate of fire back then but it's
way too high so this is a rate of fire
that you might get with maybe the Mini
Uzi with its uh smaller lighter faster
bolt that's flying back and forth there
um otherwise though it's quite well done
quite realistically modeled for the time
certainly you'll notice the ars no jokes
fellow Brits please automatic repetition
and safe currently this is on repetition
I.E semi-automatic that's a British
Commonwealth type Turner phrase the
magazine catch being a little bit
unusual off to the side we do see the
player sort of fumble with that though
pretty good job
now back in 2008 I had I'm pretty sure
no idea what shotgun we've just seen
probably even assumed that it was a bit
of a made-up one regardless it's one of
these it's the the Benelli M4 super 90.
pretty well represented it does what
you'd expect handling wise I mean these
guys are not apart from Bill of course
who's a veteran but wouldn't have
encountered one of these they're not
expected to be sort of current and
competent experts on all of these
Firearms so that it's not necessary that
they follow any particular drill what
bill at least would know is finger off
the trigger unless you until you're
ready to shoot and so thumbing thumbing
the cartridges in at very very high
speed because it's a fast-paced game and
we have to speed that up otherwise
you're going to get Mortal to death
that's fine but doing it while your
thing is on the trigger these days at
least makes me Twitch uh it probably
didn't in 2008 so much
they're coming
a minigun major feature of this game
absolutely can't get through the game
without it with these um sort of
standoffs that you have to periodically
do lots of fun to use they got the the
general sort of appearance and feel
pretty right I mean I don't think in
detail it's very close to her and then
134 but video game terms you feel like
you're shooting a Minigun the rate of
fire important to get that right and
that that feels right at least I haven't
tried to calculate it it's difficult
with such a high rate of fire gun to
make it still feel Punchy because if if
you kept the sort of volume levels of
the other guns and but gave it the same
rate of fire it probably sounds weird so
it's been sort of engineered to sound
like a mini gun does on a video clip I
suppose I often feel with mounted guns
and games especially minigun or Gatling
type guns you don't really feel like
you're having much effect with this I
actually felt like I was able to
swinging Traverse as they say and I've
said in the um machine gun Corps to
actually hit multiple enemies and and it
feels like it's actually having an
effect for me it's a great blend of
recognizably a real gun does it work
exactly like the real thing probably not
but does it matter I mean unlimited ammo
obviously absolutely doesn't matter in
the context of the game it's it does
what it needs to
reloading
ah I'm 16. one of the better versions
out there for feeling like you're in an
action movie with an M16 which let's be
honest is the main draw of a game like
this or it was for me it even has on the
on the texture on the on the lower
receiver some markings and they are
correct markings except for the spurious
American Armory and the legally
different armalites oh cult sorry logo
but they look plausible enough
especially if you're being hounded by
zombies which we usually are in these
games now something I I have seen on the
Internet movie Firearms database spent a
long time on that site well done guys
involved in that and I remember seeing
that the m16a m16a2 was criticized
because it's not burst not three round
burst which the US issue m1602
absolutely was there is no US military
m16a2 that is automatic fire which this
is now from a gaming perspective I like
that I didn't want the a three round
burst but the the issue being pointed
out which is sort of true but sort of
wrong as well was the fact that there's
no m16a2 that has automatic on the
receiver Auto on the receiver automatic
fire coming out the end of the of the
barrel well as viewers of the royal
armories channel will hopefully no
that's not true
um so it's only the US military issue
m16a2 that cannot have
um automatic fire the m16a2 is a Colt
product line it was a whole range of
weapons here is one and trust me if you
can't see that that says m16a2 and that
says Auto this is apart from the British
military black paint as it came from the
Colt Factory it is an m16a2 that is
automatic and it's not the only one just
that in the US military that was only
adopted as the m16a3 and would not have
been marked A2 I realized this gets
confusing the bottom line is there's the
US Military m16a2 and there's the Colt
product range m1602 and all
possibilities were there with this
modular rifle to have it do almost
whatever you wanted within reason and it
would still be marked m1602 so is it
incorrect for this to have automatic via
yes still it still is because if this is
meant to be left behind by soldiers it
wouldn't be marked m16a2 and it wouldn't
be automatic however it also wouldn't be
marked American Armory and have a
spurious trademark on it so you can go
all the way down the rabbit hole on this
but at the end of the day it's a good
M16
thank you
all right I've kind of forgotten that
the the sniper rifle in this game was a
mini 14 and not an M14 or an M1A or
something it's semi-only it's it's I
guess well within the context of the
game it's powerful although zombies
don't ordinary zombies don't take much
killing in practice 5.56 or 223 round
same as the M16 in the game the only
thing that this gives you that the M16
doesn't in theory is the scope and
obviously you can put an optic on an M16
although perhaps not in the field you
know the idea here I guess is that we
found somebody's hunting rifle uh I've
I've grabbed something similar we have
Mini 14s in closer configurations to the
game rifle than this this has a well the
I think it's a beach stock it's a bit
too light colored it's pretty close the
muzzle device is different but it is um
a rigor mini 14 caliber 223 as it says
on on the back here the reason I'm
waving the magazine around separately
is that uh not having great deal
experience with the mini 14 platform I
occasionally struggle when it comes to
inserting the magazine because the the
latching point is quite far in
to the receiver the way the magazine is
shown inserted into the gun in the game
is just shove it in and it's fine it
would be if you had some experience with
the platform but it's not quite
reflecting the reality of the weapon I
don't think but hey it's something a bit
different
um for a zombie game it's instead of a
big powerful bolt action sniper and then
an assault rifle we have something where
it's a little bit Bridging the Gap it's
almost an alternative to not the assault
rifle but a but a AR-15 pattern rifle
when in reality ideally you just have
the AR and you'd stick a scope on it
possibly not one with so much
magnification as we have here and we
have uh in the game but quite happy with
it as a semi-auto sniper sort of a DMR
really that's the kind of the role it
plays in the game sort of
hey some things I'd forgotten about Left
4 Dead well two in this case the change
of the main pistol from the the cult to
the Sig P220 which we see on the on the
right there it's a sub variant that we
don't have with a with the safety on the
frame there this is a relatively unusual
combination for
a game to have your sort of standard
size pistol and then when you pick up a
second one with Left 4 Dead one we had
two of the same that would be logical
way to do it games obviously have let
you dual wield differentially as it was
a gun you pick up a different gun you're
holding one in each hand that's always
cool yeah Call of Duty famous for that
the game automatically giving you a
different pistol as your second pistol
is kind of interesting I can't remember
how it handles that in terms of what you
see lying on the ground but uh
regardless you end up with a Glock in
your left hand a Sig in your right hand
so the element of realism would be that
in some crisis situation like this you
if you really felt you had to shoot two
guns at once
um you'd be stuck with whatever you had
you wouldn't be able to have two
pristine identical examples of the same
gun I will say the Glock 26 in terms of
perspective on the screen there
proportions don't quite look right to me
I'm not sure why I think it might be a
bit too long in the barrel the real
thing is very very short in front of the
trigger guard but it could be
perspective let's go
I'm not sure why but I don't really
remember using the MP5 in Left 4 Dead 2
which is weird because I played lots of
it and I love mp5s as a lot of you know
I only have two criticisms one would be
the metallic components are very shiny
more so than they ought to be really
it's not like it's shown to have lost a
load of finish and been polished to a
high shine so that I think is a sort of
period Graphics issue more so than
anything else otherwise it looks really
good the cocking handle sorry three
things the cooking bundle is too narrow
and it should be
chunkier than that most egregiously the
only thing that really matters here
there's no HK slap the reload is a
legitimate alternative way of reloading
the mv5 albeit not necessarily
recommended with a full magazine because
of the pressure of this of the spring uh
pushing up the rounds more importantly
yeah just it means you don't get the
cool animation
now the AK I do remember using and as I
possibly even knew at the time but now
know this is what we would call an akm
the modernized and N for the site rail
on the left side of the receiver for
Night Vision Optics
um they're relatively unusual in the
scheme of things just because there are
so many AKs without but it's that's what
that bracket is on the left side there
we don't have at this point that sort of
customization so it's not used I think
they all come with either lasers or
lights in these games there's no real
customization that I remember it's a
good effort for an AK it's got a good
rate of fire one thing I do actually
appreciate that I suspect some people
might roll their eyes at is the fact
that the players using their right hand
to perform the reload and cocking the
weapon oddly enough although there's no
way that the characters in the game
should know this that's correct for Cold
War Soviet handling of this type of
weapon carried over to the AK-74 in fact
you are supposed to do all the
manipulations with your shooting hand
with your right hand it's not how it's
done today certainly not in the west but
the fact that they they're taking their
hand off taking off the magazine rocking
in a new one charging the weapon that's
actually correct but again it's one of
these things that I think about
sometimes games especially movies
um should the character know how to
handle the weapon that correctly
it's legal time this is not bad this is
this is good in fact uh We've we
actually can see at least an impression
of the Locking recesses in the barrel
and so what you can't really see is the
the LA the multi-lug bolt that's pushing
the cartridge into the chamber uh
snapping the extractor over the rim and
then locking the gun shut because this
is a pistol this is a handgun with a
rifle operating system gas operated it
will never cease to be impressive for
that reason and of course it's sheer
size and heft and power and it's 50
action Express form which uh I'm pretty
sure is what we're seeing here does
anyone deliberately choose to make their
Desert Eagle 357 or 44 when it can be
50. I doubt it everything seems present
and correct controls are all there the
general proportions are correct the
finish I like it's a stainless or nickel
and it's got some fairly plausible dirt
on it like you see that the black's
streaking above
where the bolt would be kind of imply
I'm not sure I'm not sure if the real
Desert Eagle would ever achieve that
dirt pattern but at least it implies
that this thing is seeing heavy use
which of course it is and we see other
black streaks down the side of the slide
just behind where the gas piston is
operating so yeah again I think you'd
have to shoot a desert eagle more than
your wrists would be comfortable with to
actually end up with it looking all
dirty and streaky but it adds character
and it takes it away from the sort of
Half-Life era of just shiny shiny
metallic looking textures it looks like
a sort of lived-in pistol
right so we got with it with the sequel
great sequel if it ain't broken don't
fix it but it does add some extra
options new weapons this is another one
the the Ingram model 10 uh shout out to
my colleague Mike who gets very bent out
of shape if you call this a Mach 10
um it's a Mac 10.
and it's a good job actually the they
modeled it pretty closely again the rate
of fire on this being a short compact
not quite machine pistol but is closer
to being correct than the than the quite
slow Uzi the report that the gunshots
are I don't think the zombies give them
monkeys but the um effect of the
suppressor it does sound relatively
realistic you know silencers don't
silence they just reduce the the decibel
level and it sounds like it's doing that
job even if it doesn't have that effect
in the game because we're not sure we're
not fighting humans now um a weird
quirky feature and I'm not talking about
the laser sight which I've only just
remembered was an optional pickup in
these games that's clamped around
there's some zip ties
what it's clamped around is what's
interesting now under here you can just
about see under the cover it is a two
diameter suppressor but at no point is
there a perforated heat shield around
the suppressor today you might well find
a handguard with cooling lightning
perforations in it and then the
suppressor is sleeved under that but
that's not the case with the Mac 10.
what I think has happened here is
they've had a visual reference for the
suppressor probably without the cover on
it and for this thing
now this is not a suppressor and nor is
it a barrel extension because unlike
some games you can't just screw on a
barrel extension and magically have it
improve your your velocity or whatever
what it is is just something to hang on
to and it is a heat shield because
obviously you can't just hang on to the
barrel and then you end up with a Mac 10
that looks like this
there's I think there's a really great
balance of guns in in these two games in
terms of what you start out with what
you pick up when you find them how
effective they are and how they how
different they all feel I think the M60
kind of underlines that quite nicely
it's not the fixed super powerful
unlimited ammo mini gun but it's
definitely more capable than the M16 or
the AK looks right sounds pretty good
might be a missed opportunity to not
have the player character hold the loose
belt over their arm like Rambo given
that it's by default a hip firing and
View and not a aim down sights thing but
I can't really complain about it maybe
it could have more punch in terms of
volume but uh still sounds like a
machine gun to me
foreign
[Applause]
scarf another of the assault rifles
obviously and it's not bad we got the
the semi-infamous reciprocating cocking
handle that uh if if you're not careful
we'll immediately tear your thumb off at
the root um obviously not not really the
bigger problem is actually interfering
with the operation of the weapon and
stopping it from working different
schools of thought on that it's
Faithfully represented here that's
that's what we care about you know
obviously with with very minimal almost
non-existent upgrade abilities for this
you're not really taking advantage of
this modern modular platform that can be
accessorized you you are cable tying on
off camera a laser essentially or a
light you're not taking advantage of the
Optics rail ability to mount proper sort
of laser and light modules you're not
you're not you're not using it to its
potential which I suspect is why in
reality if you have to come across or
open like this when are you gonna get
the chance to uh to upgrade it like you
would if you were in special operations
forces or something so it's not there's
nothing inherently wrong with that and
it's just how the game is what it does
is make it hard to differentiate this
from the M16 and so I think that's why
they've gone for burst fire which the
FNS scar to my knowledge and certainly
the the standard versions do not um
there might be a prototype at FN her
style somewhere that is burst capable
but um the commercially available the
military issue no it's select fire
semi-automatic and automatic so they've
by having to add this weapon later in
the cycle as it were they've hamstrung
themselves in terms of that slight into
realism of they've got an M16 there too
that's A2 that's automatic and it's been
succeeded effectively at this point by a
burst fire scar so although although
there are m16a2s that are automatic
there are not scars that have burst so
if we want to get all gunnerd about it
this is a little bit jarring
right guys those were the guns of Left
for Dead one and two um I hope someone
learns to count to three that's that's
well I'll say on that one great fun to
go through those again it's been many
years uh really nostalgic for me to go
through those games absolutely loved
them a shout out to my wife for the
first time uh because she was absolutely
notorious for leaving the rest of the
team behind and running off ahead to get
to the objective you know it's true
all right guys we'll see you again next
time on this series